voilà donc ce que nous savons maintenant
que c'est le juge
pour paul lefèvre qu'il l'a rencontré il
ne s'agissait pas bien sûr de chercher à
percer le secret de l'instruction
mais de faire le bilan de trois ans de
vie d'un homme plongé dans ce dossier
qui 24 heures sur 24 a en tête cet
instantané
le moment où grégory a été tué à leur
première question la sphère grégory
aujourd'hui est ce une enquête raté et
qu'on essaie de rattraper ou une affaire
vraiment exceptionnel
réponse du juge simon à paul le faire
c'est gênant de vous répondre et d'avoir
l'air de dire je suis en train de
traiter une affaire exceptionnelle mais
je pense en toute objectivité que c'est
une affaire exceptionnelle unis ni
exceptionnel exceptions près
vraiment ça fait maintenant ça tombe
d'années que vous êtes plongés chercha
dossier est ce que vous connaissez le
meurtrier non je peux pas vous rendre
est ce qu'il est possible et connaître
le meurtrier
c'est mon rôle est une affaire
exceptionnelle comme ça peut-elle
déboucher sur sur un mystère qu'on
pourra jamais
je crois que tout absolument tout doit
être entrepris pour trouver il n'est pas
possible de laisser dans les annales
judiciaires une affaire qui a tellement
tellement préoccupé l'opinion à qui la
préoccupe toujours sans réponse alors on
ne fait souvent ce procès d'être long de
faire durer interminablement me prétend
parfois d'ailleurs des attentions à
c'est assez désagréable on dit que je
fais durée pour éviter que jean marie
villemin soit jugé que je fais du ray
oui mais c'est pas vrai elle examine son
jugement
ils sont jugés de france passeront le
sait pas de problème mais il sera jugé
dans un contexte bien précis qui est
sera de toute façon éclairée au maximum
par conséquent et c'est tout ça peut
être aussi bon que redoutable pour lui
l'option publique à l'impression que le
secret de l'instruction cache le temps
perdu
est-ce qu'on a perdu du temps dans cette
affaire dont je peux même pas dire ça on
n'a pas si compliqué au point que non on
n'a pas perdu de temps personne n'a
perdu du temps même le premier jeu
même le premier jeu et c'est des gens
qui mentent
dans ce dossier probablement mais cet
enfant qu'il a eu le riz qui est là le
départ mme malheureux de cette affaire
est ce que maintenant après deux ans de
recherches
vous savez précisément comment et où il
est mort
au fond on sait quand ça je ne peux pas
vous répondre
c'est pour beaucoup de roches vertes ça
ça c'est un élément important qui est
que vous estimez devoir être couverts
par ce qu'alain s'occupe sérieusement sa
potentielle l'arrêt à première vue
quelque chose bien sûr mais lentement
très bien mais est-ce qu'il ya un secret
dans cette affaire parmi cette
population
on a comparé à puiser beaucoup ces gens
de camoufler un secret être lié par un
secret est ce que c'est vrai exemple
derrière un meurtre comme cela dans le
côté énigmatique ans dont j'ai parlé du
côté énigmatique est forcément un secret
ce secret y résident dans le mobile que
la recherche du mobile et nous avons mis
à un accent considérable sur la
recherche du mobile voulez vous dire à
quoi je suis arrivé je ne peux pas
mourir
est ce que dans cette affaire là on peut
atteindre la ligue et d'écrans mondial
des grands exemples de cette affaire on
n'a pas la vérité vous répondre c'est
une affaire délicate parce que vous
pourriez en tirer une appréciation de
l'état où j'en suis on est enfin devenu
ce truc dossier franchement bon alors je
prends ma question autrement
est ce que dans excuse me est ce que
c'est une est ce que c'est un dossier
dans laquelle on connaître un jour la
vérité mon sens oui donc durera un jour
l'autre plus de mystère grégory je pense
ça va être une affaire qui va encore
avoir un rebondissement ou une affaire
qui va se terminer comme ça devrait être
bouclée ficelé comme on dit je pense pas
qu'elle se termine sans rebondissements
ah bon il va se passer des choses dans
la terre c'est probable oui douce qui
vont surprendre
peut-être vu vider moi vous avez tous
les éléments dans le dossier il suffit
de les mettre dans l'or oui c'est ça la
vermine main ou plutôt la feria c'est çà
s'est
tout tout est dans le dossier il suffit
de trouver la façon de les assembler et
d avaler boucher cellule mobile et de
bien peser la valeur des éléments
oui et tout ça ça débouche sur un mobile
et un personnage un mobile un ou des
personnages
pourquoi des personnages ça peut y voir
plusieurs que c'est une possibilité à
gérer dans une fois vous allez avoir
refermé ce dossier d'une manière ou
d'une autre
est ce que vous allez retourner sur les
lieux
on est sûrement
pour quoi faire
est ce que vous serez sûr à ce moment là
d'avoir découvert la vérité je souhaite
vivement
je dois quelque chose à quelqu'un oui
alors paul lefèvre après avoir entendu
cette interview du juge simon on a
l'impression qu'il sait et que bientôt
nous nous serons est ce que c'est un peu
votre conviction vous qui êtes restés
produit quelques heures pour moi
j'observe le suivons depuis pas mal de
temps et c'est à versailles climatiques
un peu un métier tanoh stamm très
intelligent c'est une mécanique
intellectuelle
moi j'ai je vais observer depuis
longtemps et pas lancer plusieurs heures
je suis convaincu qu'il connaît le
mobile qu'il a découvert le mobile et je
suis convaincu qu'il sait la vérité
alors paul mais c'est une je le sens
comme ça paul pourquoi le juge vous a
accordé une interview alors que l'on
sait que cet homme jamais accordé une
seule interview
eh bien c'est la question qui me taraude
la tête de vieux héros survenu dijon je
veux dire que je suppose qu'il a une
certaine estime pour moi c'est vrai que
dès le désert des des mois et des mois
que je l'en bête
mais ça n'est il ya une raison je ne la
connais pas la raison que ce que ce
magistrat qui est qui qui est d'un un
homme de du secret brusquement acceptent
de parler il est parlé non seulement
avec les mots mais avec ces regards des
attitudes je crois que ça fait partie de
sa stratégie d'une semaine qui sommes
d'une semaine qui s'annonce cruciale
alors notons donc quelques éléments de
cette interview comme à la télé à
l'instant le juge koné visiblement le
mobile un schéma prévoit des
rebondissements il a parlé de personnage
au pluriel et pas d'un seul responsable
de cette affaire il considère qu'on n'a
pas perdu de temps ça c'est nouveau
depuis le début et puis aussi son
émotion à la fin tu n'as peut être lui
même mais qui est peut-être aussi la
révélation d'autres choses ah c'est
certainement ce magistrat est un grand
père il ya des petits enfants du même
âge que grégory ça c'est certainement la
révélation d'un attachement profond à la
recherche d' avait été non seulement le
magistrat mais aussi l'homme qui ne peut
pas concevoir qu'on est une enfant comme
ça alors demain dans le journal de jean
claude bourret à 13 heures la suite de
l'interview de justin ont fait face sur
quoi sur un particulier son jugement sur
la procédure judiciaire et l'attitude de
la presse dans cette affaire ce n'est
pas toujours très trop merci paul rendez
vous donc avec vous demain à présent